close to six million congolese forced
from their homes a third of the
population going hungry and all after
decades of conflict but the democratic
republic of congo is top of the most
neglected crises worldwide according to
the norwegian refugee council
the aid organization lists 10 countries
all of them in africa which have
displacement crises that don't get
enough media attention
the countries include burkina faso
burundi cameroon chad ethiopia nigeria
and mali south sudan is number four on
the list the world's youngest country
faced conflict just two years after
independence in 2011.
a third of its 12 million people were
forced from their homes
fighting largely ended when a peace deal
was signed in 2018.
since then floods have displaced nearly
a million more
our camp was established two years ago
and we came from the north but here we
have humanitarian issues there is no
food no access to farming and no
education
sudan is also on the list more than 2
million have been displaced in the
western region of darfur since fighting
there started in 2003
hundreds of thousands remain in camps
despite a peace deal signed two years
ago
in may fighting in west r4 forced around
35 000 families from their homes
we were attacked and forced to leave our
homes with nothing
now we have nothing to eat and are
staying out in the open under the sun
the norwegian refugee council says the
lack of media attention to the crisis
has contributed to less humanitarian and
political response
when the drc is getting so little
attention in global media it also leads
to less aid
money going there compared to ukraine
and other crises that are in the
limelight constantly
but also to
reduce political diplomatic attention
and initiatives to solve the deep crisis
in the in in the congo so we're in a
desperate situation as humanitarians on
the ground were not getting the
attention not neither the funding nor
help to solve the crisis
and as the world's attention remains
elsewhere most of the funding appeals to
respond to the crises in the countries
on the list remain low aid organizations
say that needs to change to improve the
lives of millions hibermorgan al jazeera